pour
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro dans une demi heure nous irons
à rambouillet sur place hommage à
stéphanie mère de famille fonctionnaires
de police assassiné vendredi dernier par
un islamiste tunisien
il faut cesser de nier le lien entre
immigration et terrorisme ce sont les
propos polémiques signé de valérie
pécresse ce week-end ils ont donc
soulevé pas mal de débats pas mal de
taulé alors pensez vous qu'il existe un
lien entre immigration et terrorisme
on vous pose la question sur twitter et
on en débat ce soir on en débat avec
vous on en débat aussi avec alexandre ii
vecchio bonsoir allez vous perdre on
rappelle que alexandre est journaliste
au service des bas et opinions du figaro
faut-il encore le rappeler en charge de
filières au vox et des pages débats du
figaro magazine
auteur aussi du livre indispensable à
lire sur le populisme recomposition aux
éditions du cerf
on en débat aussi comme chaque lundi
avec nicolas baverez ce bon soir nicolas
bonsoir avocat essayiste et chroniqueur
au figaro alors nicolas et est modeste
en fait parce que ce qui vous dit pas
c'est que serti des énarques mais il est
aussi et d'abord normalien et avant
également docteur en histoire donc trois
raisons de lire tous les livres que
nicolas il fallait il ya une des raisons
qui a été supprimé je le disais c'est le
dernier roman de choses que c'est de
savoir laquelle le dernier les derniers
en date c'est le monde selon tocqueville
et l' alerte democratif bref il y aura
une question au libéral et au dos mais
démocrates que vous êtes peut-on
échapper au nom des libertés publiques
au passeport sanitaires vous avez dix
minutes pour y réfléchir mon cher
nicolas
et dix minutes pour y répondre mais
d'abord d'abord on revient donc sur ce
qui s'est passé vendredi dernier à
rambouillet alors dans une demi heure
nous aurons les rassemblements les
français sont appelés à se rassembler
devant les commissariats en soutien aux
policiers
et bien sûr rassemblement dans la sous
préfecture des yvelines à rambouillet
vous pourrez le suivre en direct avec
thibault il aurait masseron notre envoyé
spécial sur place également un live
texte sur lefigaro.fr avec margot
d'avoir démarré ici en studio charlotte
barillon de bruit en attendant la
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter est
la suivante peut-on faire un lien entre
immigration et terrorisme les réponses
sûr twitter sont très polarisée certains
s'indignent que la question puisse être
posé d'autres s'indignent qu'elle n'ait
pas été posée depuis longtemps en tous
les cas elle a été soulevée
d'abord par valérie pécresse est
également vous entendrez ce qu'on a dit
à l'essayiste et ancien porte-parole des
républicains lydia guirous ce ce midi
sur ce plateau même invité du talk le
figaro avec extraire
si on veut lutter contre le terrorisme
de manière efficace il faut d'abord
cessé de nier le lien entre terrorisme
et l'immigration il y a un lien entre le
terrorisme et l'immigration notamment
l'immigration la plus récente la
deuxième le deuxième sujet c'est comment
repérer les signaux de radicalisation
comment mieux les repérer et le
troisième sujet c'est comment mettre
hors d'état de nuire les radicaliser en
évitant que dans nos prisons ils
deviennent trop élite et une fasse des
émules
donc on est obligé de faire ce lien
entre immigration et terrorisme
islamique
le terreau fertile de la radicalisation
qui mène au passage à l'acte est donc au
terrorisme c'est le communautarisme
islamique est temps qu'on n'ira pas sur
cette question là sans trembler sans
tabou on ne réussira pas à vaincre
l'islamisme radical qui fait couler le
sang sur notre territoire
alors ces propos d'abord ceux de valérie
pécresse vont confirmer tout à l'heure
par lydia guirous soutenu par didier
rous et de façon générale par tous les
ténors de l'opposition soit chez les
républicains soit au rassemblement
national ces propos ont soulevé un tollé
à gauche ou encore au gouvernement en
tous les cas chez le porte parole
gabriella talent qui s'est indigné de ce
lien qui a été fait entre immigration et
terrorisme
c'est un fait que l'agresseur est issu
de l'immigration qu'il a été qu'il est
entré dans notre pays clandestinement
qu'il a été régularisée parce que je
refuserai toujours c'est de tirer un
trait entre l'immigration et terrorisme
je vois ça je vois très bien que
certains ont ce projet politique l'a
alors alexandre ii vecchio je vous vois
sourire en entendant gabriela talent
certes jamais leurs chaînes et paire
sorti sans l'étranger djamel dorchen
donc c'est l'assassin de présumer un sol
en quête de cette policière à
rambouillet mais à mehdi coulibaly
l'assaillant de l'hyper cacher les
frères kwasi les auteurs de l'attentât
de l'attak de charlie hebdo des frères
abdeslam impliqué dans les attentats du
13 novembre étaient français sans parler
de michael et harpons l'assaillant de la
préfecture de police de paris français
et dont la famille était française
française même avant que vous et moi
alors deux choses d'abord parce que
personne ne met à signe égal entre
terrorisme et l'immigration c'est la
rhétorique de gabriel à talons je pense
que par contre les ténors de
l'opposition disent qu'il ya un lien
entre les deux pour ce qui est le cas de
rambouillet c'est didot puis ce qui est
effectivement il est c'est un immigré
mais en plus il est en retrait sur le
territoire en situation illégale et il y
est resté 10 ans en situation illégale
ensuite pour répondre à vos objections
sur l'e42 terroristes qui ont frappé
depuis l'attentât de charlie hebdo en
2015 il y en a seulement 4 qui ne sont
pas étrangers ou d'origine étrangère
donc effectivement il ya un lien alors
effectivement les mesures à prendre sont
différentes selon
le selon cissé des immigrés directement
voir des immigrés illégaux et cissé sont
des français d'origine étrangère là
c'est plus un problème effectivement
d'intégration qui va falloir régler
parce qu'une fois que les personnes sont
françaises voilà ça se gère différemment
mais de manière générale oui le problème
d'intégration est liée à une politique
d'immigration mal maîtrisée qui fait qu'
il ya des enclaves communautaire qui est
secret dans certains quartiers que la
population à être totalement homogène et
que du coup ils ont beau être français
il ne se considère pas eux mêmes comme
français se considèrent même comme
adversaire de la france donc ça vous dit
si je me suis c'est que ceux qui sont
d'origine étrangère ne peuvent pas
s'intégrer à cause d'une immigration
massive c'est exactement
nicolas à l'avant de quoi parle d'abord
on quand on parle de terrorisme
il faut être clair c'est un terme
générique mais le problème qui se pose
là nos sociétés c'est le problème du
terrorisme islamiste pour l'instant
puisque c'est très clairement la menace
prioritaire
alors quand on regarde les attentats qui
se sont déroulées depuis 2015 qui sont
les auteurs et comment ça s'organise on
a eu et effectivement on l'a rappelé
charlie hebdo est donc là ce sont des
réseaux qui était organisée sur le
territoire français avec y compris des
français
ensuite on a le bataclan là c'est un
commando qui est projeté depuis le
moyen-orient et enfin on a depuis c'est
la réalité la plus récente en tout cas
les derniers attentats
ce sont des individus
qui sont effectivement généralement
d'origine étrangère français ou ou d où
des immigrés en situation irrégulière ou
récemment régularisés c'est ce
terrorisme de proximité qui est
aujourd'hui le plus présent parce que
depuis la défaite de l'état islamique en
syrie en irak
la projection de commando est devenu
plus compliqué les réseaux ont quand
même été assez bien démantelé donc pour
répondre à la question est ce que et
s'était ensuite donc sur cette question
du terrorisme de proximité le lien ça a
été rappelé quand on regarde les auteurs
des attentats ou il y a un lien est ce
que ce lien est automatique
la réponse est non puisque on a aussi
des français qui sont convertis et qui
sont pas tous d'origine
qui était pas du tout forcément des
musulmans à l'origine donc on ne peut
pas faire un lien automatique entre les
deux donc quand on vient ensuite à
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est là où
je crois que c'est pour ça que c'est
important de raisonner et d'éviter de
tomber dans l'indignation parce que
qu'est ce qui nous manque
il nous manque d'avoir une stratégie
globale et dans cette stratégie globale
il est certain qu'il ya un volet
immigration un volet intégration et un
volet contrôle de l'immigration
mais ça peut pas il n'y a pas de réponse
uniquement sécuritaire et il n'y a pas
de réponse simplement par l'éventuelle
blocage des éventuels blocages des
frontières alors donc c est si vous
voulez ce qu'on voit en ce moment c'est
à dire que comme à chaque attentat on va
passer à un nouveau bout de loi qui ne
sera peu ou prou pas appliquée à partir
du dernier attentat
très franchement ça ne fait pas une ça
ne fait pas une stratégie c'est vrai
qu'on paye le fait que depuis le début
de ce quinquennat il ya un réveil tardif
mais il n'y a pas eu de prise en compte
de cette question de la sécurité
intérieure comme d'ailleurs vraiment de
la sécurité extérieure pendant au moins
les quatre premières années du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron alors il
n'y a pas eu de prise en compte de
la sécurité a même eu un dîner il ya eu
un déni des problématiques de sécurité
intérieure à l'extérieur depuis les
quatre premières années il nous reste
encore une année et sans doute une
campagne présidentielle derrière où la
question sera peut-être peut-être sans
doute abordée en tous les cas d'après ce
que je comprends de ce que vous dites
vous l'espérez alors justement qu'est-ce
que il faudrait faire pour justement
s'attaquer à ce volet là en tous les cas
si appartement où vous dites l'un et
l'autre qu'il y a un lien entre les deux
phénomènes
comment justement on se sent sa taxe à
cette question alors s'arrête un peu
fausse pardonnez-moi mais trois choses
d'abord la question la question de
l'immigration illégale parce qu'il se
trouve que cette personne pour le
dernier attentat resté 10 ans en
situation irrégulière
il sait il se trouve que de manière
générale 80 % des personnes qui sont sur
le territoire en situation irrégulière
ne sont pas reconduits est-ce qu'on a
tout fait pour faire appliquer la loi
la réponse et dont on nous dit c'est
compliqué parce que les pays ne veulent
pas les reprendre etc
il n'y a pas que ça il y a un volet qui
concerne notamment le droit européen
puisque la directive retour fait par
exemple que
on ne reconduit pas automatiquement les
personnes il faut leur demander poliment
de retourner directement chez elle c'est
la loi c'est quand même une vision
bisounours des choses les gens une fois
qu'ils sont au fond le territoire si on
les reconduit pas de force ça ne pourra
pas fonctionner ensuite toujours
directive européenne jusqu'ici jusqu'à
il y a très peu s'introduire
illégalement sur le territoire français
était un délit ça a été supprimé donc là
il ya deux choses à revoir en termes
d'état de droit l'état de droit j'y suis
attaché mais on peut le revoir le
modifier donc je pense que la solution
la saison passée par le référendum mais
de faire en sorte que les lois
françaises
soit constitutionnellement au dessus des
lois européennes
le référendum fera aussi parce que ça
passera par le suffrage populaire que
les juges ne pourront plus finalement
faire la loi parce que ça passe par les
juges donc ça c'est une une première
chose concernant l'immigration illégale
alors jusque là aussi économiquement on
veut disait quelqu'un qui dit alexandre
pas de joindre en vain puisque vous
aviez de trois points on va essayer les
erreurs des brièvement mais sur les
migrations illégales
c'est ce que j'ai vu je rêvais d'un
homme pour que la loi française soit
supérieure à la loi européenne
et j'imagine vous êtes d'accord avec
vole pas eu qui dit qu'il faut expulser
automatiquement les
les personnes qui sont arrivées
clandestinement sur le sur le tweet sur
les abolir la directive retour de ne pas
coller juste un mot sur l'immigration
illégale et après j'étais rebelle il ya
aussi sans doute un volet économique il
faut pas être naïf le patronat a besoin
dans les auvergnats et la restauration
de mares d'oeuvre bon marché
là on peut augmenter les comics et je
pense que nicolas aura des réponses
en tous les cas y ait des questions sur
ce volet là mais avant justement sur la
partie précisément puisque vous parlez
soulever les questions d'état de droit
nicolas sur précisément cette idée de à
la fois abolir cette directive
européenne la directive retour et
ensuite le faire-part par référendum en
instituts aux français d'abord les
problèmes de l'immigration en france ne
sont pas entièrement liée à l'europe
loin de là je rappelle que le début de
la politique d'immigration c'est les
années 60 effectivement pour l'industrie
festif et oui été lancée sur les
migrations et donc en réalité il et
c'est là où il faut quand même être
assez précis le problème de
l'immigration en france n'est pas un
problème européen
le problème c'est qu'on n'a pas de
stratégie globale de lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est ça notre problème est
donc de fait il faut une stratégie
globale
elle doit avoir quatre volets il ya un
volet sécuritaire sur lequel
effectivement il faut renforcer l'état
régalien qui a été quand même
extrêmement mise à mal je le rappelle
qu' aujourd'hui l'état providence et 34%
du pib' l'état régalien ses 2,6 pour
cent du pipe dans tout est dit ensuite
la coordination
la sécurité entre intérieur et extérieur
évidemment le deuxième point la justice
donc la justice elle plusieurs problèmes
premier problème effectivement elle est
sous financé elle est lente et en plus
quand elle prend des décisions toute une
partie de ces décisions ne sont pas
appliquées puisque effectivement on sait
qu'on a hautmont plus de 200000 mesure
d'expulsion du territoire français qui
restent inappliquées
troisième chose il y a effectivement le
contrôle de l'immigration
et donc il est clair que la france
devrait passer à un système de quotas et
ça rejoint le problème de l'économie
puisque effectivement il y à des métiers
qui sont en tension sur lequel on peut
avoir besoin de gens en revanche c'est
vraiment pas la peine d'apporter des des
chômeurs supplémentaires et enfin il y à
l'intégration et donc si on arrive à
construire un discours raisonnable et
une politique autour de ça on pourra
arriver à régler
à terme le problème du terrorisme
islamiste
si on continue à faire des lois au coup
par coup à aller et venir à se financer
l'état régalien effectivement à ne pas
appliquer les décisions de justice eh
ben on en sortir on en sortir à partir
donc voilà le et si vous voulez sur
l'idée du référendum d'alexandre vous en
pensez quoi
mais où on fasse si on estime que c'est
effectivement une des clefs du
redressement du pays
pourquoi pas faire un référendum mais le
référendum si vous voulez il est pas
tellement à faire entre guillemets
contre le contre l'europe parce qu'il ya
des pays en europe qui ont aussi des
immigrés où ça se passe beaucoup mieux
l'allemagne est un pays qui a de alors
l'immigration est plutôt sûr que c'est
pas exactement mais force est de
constater qu'il ya des pays où ça se
passe mieux que rec en france et
effectivement le contrairement à ce
qu'avait dit le garde des sceaux au
départ le problème de la violence dans
notre pays est pas un problème de
sentiment d'insécurité
il y a un problème majeur que les
citoyens perçoivent clairement c'est
pour ça que ça sera sûrement un des
grands thèmes de l'élection
présidentielle mais maintenant il faut
apporter des réponses qui soit à la fois
responsable efficace est compatible avec
l'état de droit et on peut tout à fait
le faire je salue philippe claudius ce
pôle qui nous olympe christian les en a
qui nous ont rejoints et qu'ils nous
envoient leurs messages je peux pas tous
leur sort sur un point de connexion
internet sur ma tablette mais je vois
que vincent le noble vous alimentez
également avec tous les articles du
figaro alexandre justement je reviens je
rebondis sur ce que vient de dire
également nicolas est ce que vous
commenciez à dire tout à l'heure il ya
justement philippe qui nous dit nous
n'avons pas besoin de livres ça c'est
une allusion au métier justement de
djamel gorgen ce qui a permis la
régularisation c'est d'avoir un travail
chauffeur livreur en l'occurrence et
dans le figaro aujourd'hui patrick
stefanini dit que les besoins
économiques ne so
ce ne saurait suffire si on veut éviter
avoir d'avoir recruté systématiquement
des étrangers pour ce type de métier il
faut revaloriser en france les
conditions de travail les besoins
économiques ne saurait être un alibi
pour ne pas lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine
c'est finalement en vertu du travail qui
a été donnée à jamais le coeur chan qui
l'a permis qui ce qui a permis d'avoir
sa régularisation
l'espèce d'évolution à la britannique
finalement ou pas arriver clandestins
sur le sur le territoire mais si on a un
travail on obtient oui moi je pense que
là c'est une prime à la fraude et à
d'autres pays qu'il faut autrement je
pense au canada où il prit fond de
l'immigration est connu que ça paye plus
libérale plus multiculturel risque que
le nôtre qui est peut être critiquable
d'un autre côté ils ont moins de
problèmes d'insécurité parce que
justement l'immigration et sélectionnés
en amont et pas
ensuite une fois que les gens soient
arrivées ce qui permet en plus d'avoir
des pratiques qui voilà qui sont des
pratiques à mon avis est malsaine de
sous payer les gens parce que c'est bien
que quand on a des employés en situation
irrégulière on peut les exploiter donc
je pense que les choses doivent être
claires et régulée et que le système
britannique n'est pas nécessairement un
bon système
et d'ailleurs si ils sont venus aux
briques side c'est aussi parce que toute
une partie de la population britannique
qui était devenue extrêmement hostile à
l'immigration ou du moins à la politique
d'immigration qui était mené il ya une
volonté de reprendre leur destin en main
sur ce point donc je sais que je joue là
j'ai répondu à votre question mais pour
poursuivre ma réflexion j'ai proposé un
certain que justement non mais pour
répondre vite le
effectivement bon ou canada australie
nouvelle zélande c'est des situations
très particulières parce que ce sont
quand même des pays vide donc et qui
sont structurellement en manque de deux
populations des îles saint jean seront
bien sûr le oui et des îles au moins
pour australie et nouvelle zélande les
quotas ça règle le problème parce qu'à
partir du moment où on fait venir des
gens par quotas sur un certain nombre de
métiers en tension ça veut dire que les
gens viennent dans des conditions
régulières et on est bien d'accord sur
le fait que la situation d'aujourd'hui
est insupportable où le séjour illégal
est considéré dans la réalité comme
séjour légal
et ça ça ne peut pas être tenable à
terme donc ils certain que quand
quelqu'un est jugée comme étant en
séjour irrégulier
il a vocation à partir du territoire que
ce départ doit être effectif et que la
multiplication des surtout la non
exécution ce qu'avait dit la cour des
comptes un cdn exécuté à hauteur de 96
ou 97% et du point de vue même de
l'étape droit c'est absolument intenable
droite de tonnes on peut pas on peut pas
avoir des juridictions qui rend des
décisions qui sont inappliquée hauteur
de 96 ou 97%
il faut bien voir que sade est légitime
on va ensuite il faut pas s'étonner que
la justice soit des légitimes un dernier
point
alexandre vous aviez un troisième aspect
rapidement parce que de aux labels
parce que là on a parlé de lire il
l'immigration irrégulière mais il ya
quand même le problème de l'immigration
tout court je pense que c'est un
processus historique qu'on en a perdu la
maîtrise à partir des années 60 70
je dirais 60 parce que l'immigration
change de l'action on passe d'une
immigration européenne de travail et
temporaires rappelons que deux tiers des
italiens sont repartis à une immigration
de personnes qui vont s'installer
durablement qui sont plus européens donc
l'intégration va être plus difficile en
plus on a passé colonial avec eux et
ensuite il ya le regroupement familial à
partir des années 70 ce qui complique la
donne et aujourd'hui il ya quand même
45% de l'immigration qui vient vient le
regroupement familial là encore le
conseil d'état et la loi on a voulu
changer la loi pour limiter le
regroupement familial le conseil d'état
puis le conseil constitutionnel s'ils
sont opposés là encore je suis désolé
voilà je pense qu'on va être désaccords
avec nicolas bat brest mais il faut
revoir l'état de droit pour modifier ça
avoir une cour à un plus grand contrôle
de notre immigration
mais comment voulez revoir voir l'état
de droit dans ce cas là il faut de
nouveau faire ça peut être fait en même
temps de nouveau faire un référendum
pour que le cos tissu conseil
constitutionnel se limite au contrôle
des lois c'est tout simplement vous
confirmé le désaccord nicolas n'ont en
tout cas je confirme que si on veut
revenir sur le sait effectivement ça
relève du référendum je donne la parole
aux internautes paul qui nous dit quand
la france sortira de l'espace schengen
en tout cas c'est une question qui pose
alors philippe naudy le blocage des
frontières est quand même un moyen de
limiter les risques là aussi c'est une
question qui nous posent à l'arrière
claudius nous dit lié l'intégration au
terrorisme est une manipulation
dangereuse épaules estime qu'il faut
revoir et arrêter dit-il schengen on
nous posait la question pensez vous
qu'il existe un lien entre terrorise
entre immigration et terrorisme suite
aux propos de valérie pecresse et d'un
certain nombre de responsables de
l'opposition réelle est de l'opposition
rassemblés nationale et vous répondez
oui à 73 % avec des réponses
en tous les cas dans les commentaires
qui sont très polarisée
on le rappelle l'autre question qu'on
pose sur twitter maintenant peut-être
que justement il a eu un petit peu plus
que 10 minutes nicolas baverez ça va
pouvoir y répondre et on aura le
contrepoint en tout cas les objections
d'alexandre peut-on échapper aux
passeports sanitaire donc l'autre
question qu'on pose sur twitter c'est le
débat en fait qui agite la majorité la
république en marche a lancé en réalité
une consultation aujourd'hui auprès de
ses adhérents sur ces questions alors
quelle forme ça prendrait bien ce serait
à travers l'application tous antico vide
et on signalerait si on a un vaccin
un test pcr négatif ou une sérologie qui
montre que l'on est immunisée qu'on a en
tous les cas des anticorps qui nous unit
me disent qu'ils immunise contre
coronavirus alors avant d'en débattre
voici deux points de vue d'abord plutôt
pour plutôt favorable la secrétaire
d'état à l'économie à la nièce panier
rues d'acheter
alors à l'intérieur de l'union c'est un
travail qui est mené en ce moment pour
aligner les conditions de voyage ont a
priori on est sur un schéma où il faut
pouvoir prouver soit par un test soit
par une sérologie soit par une
vaccination que où on est apte à voyager
qu'on ne présente pas de risque
individuelle est plutôt contre la
ministre de la culture
roselyne bachelot
on se dirige vers un face à lutter pour
entrer dans les cinémas les théâtres les
c'est un outil il s'agit d'abord de le
préparer techniquement oui j'ai parce
que il y avait quand même des
difficultés et ensuite de voir son
acceptabilité par la population mais ça
vaut le savoir à la pause les bancs des
problèmes éthiques mois conditionné mon
ministre de la culture conditionné
l'ouverture d'un lieu de culture
l'entrée dans un lieu de culture un
passeport sanitaires j'avoue que j'ai
beaucoup de mal alors ligne et
l'acceptabilité lier cette mesure à
l'acceptabilité auprès de l'opinion
c'est intéressant ce que soulève
roselyne bachelot dans la mesure où
alors on vous pose la question sur
twitter vous vous êtes plutôt vous pensé
qu' on ne peut pas échapper un passeport
sanitaire en tout cas ceux qui ont
répondu sur twitter vous pouvez
continuer à y répondre en majorité en
revanche les sondages sont clairs 1 pour
l'instant les français sont
majoritairement contre cette idée qu'en
pense le tocqueville ya donc hamid et
des libertés fondamentales des droits
des invisibles des individus que vous
êtes moi je suis pour le passeport
sanitaire parce que précisément nom de
au nom d'une conception
bien comprise de la liberté le choix il
est entre coire le choix il est entre la
poursuite de la fermeture
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe au
brésil ou en inde
on n'est pas sorti de cette épidémie
aujourd'hui l'économie française
fonctionne 7% en dessous de son niveau
de la fin 2019 s'est pas seulement un
problème économique on est en train de
détruire des pans entiers d'activités
aéronautiques l'hôtellerie la culture
l'événementiel et ont détruit les gens
qui travaillaient avec ces secteurs-là
et on laisse s'accumuler des problèmes
sociaux psychologiques mentaux qui vont
et des problèmes sanitaires puisque les
gens par ailleurs peuvent pas se faire
soigner sur les autres pathologies qui
vont nous poursuivre pendant des années
donc est-ce que ce passeport est utile
réponse oui pour deux choses c'est la
condition pour pouvoir reprendre un
certain nombre d'activités pourra
voyager pour pouvoir entrer dans des
salles de spectacles ou des enceintes
sportives
c'est aussi la manière de lutter contre
les contrefaçons de vaccins les fautes
est on a vu arriver déjà pas mal les
fauves accents donc
deuxièmement elle se dit certain temps
et est ce que cette attentatoires aux
libertés
réponse non ça existe déjà si vous
voulez mettre en votre enfant à la
crèche ou à l'école primaire il faut
qu'ils aient des vaccins si vous vouliez
vacciner aller dans un certain nombre de
pays
vous deviez avoir des vaccins contre la
fièvre jaune ou autre et est-ce que
c'est contraire à l'éthique
où est l'égalité non parce que je
rappelle que la définition de l'égalité
c'est principe d'égalité à condition
qu'ils soient dans les mêmes conditions
quelqu'un qui est vacciné et qui a la
foi est protégé et qui ne présentent pas
de risques envers autrui qu'il soit
traité d'une manière différente que
celui qui n'est pas vacciné et qui court
en risque pour lui-même et qui ont fait
courir à d'autres eh ben c'est tout à
fait normal et ça ne pose aucun problème
et ce par quoi je terminerais c'est que
en plus on a des exemples concrets
regardons israël israël est revenu à la
vie normale grâce à l'om il ya beaucoup
de contestations à la vaccination au nom
de ce principe là oui parce qu'une
partie des reliefs
voilà mais il n'empêche que
on peut pas nier que la société
israélienne ses roues et regardons les
britanniques c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer alors en revanche
là où ce gouvernement est comme
d'habitude
étrange c'est l'idée d'expliquer que
c'est l'application qui est un ratage
absolue stoppant tiko vide qui est un
truc franco français et qui ne marche
pas qui va être le support de tout ça il
y as tu vois que il faut là pour le coup
que ce soit un dispositif européen et
qui permettent évidemment de réouvrir
aussi l'espace européen parce qu'on en a
besoin pour des raisons économiques mais
surtout pour des raisons pour des
raisons pour des raisons humaines notre
point de vue alexandre pas pour aller
dans le sens de nicolas
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans les épaves les personnes non
vaccinées ne peuvent sortir sans subir
une quarantaine quarantaine à leur tour
c'est une consigne des ars notamment
nouvelle aquitaine le conseil de la
santé publique aujourd'hui souhaite
qu'on abandonne les gestes barrières
pour les personnes vaccinées vacciner
donc même s'il n'est pas encore autorisé
promulgué le pass vaccinale existe dans
les faits même s'il est refusé par 52%
d'ailleurs je trouve cette espèce de
débat lancé par la république en marche
bien hypocrite puisque il ya déjà le
principe d'un ils appellent ça passe
pour vert et donc pas espoir sanitaire
parce que ça sonne mieux à l'oreille
mais qui a été voté par par le parlement
européen donc donc les les choses sont
déjà en cours
moi je suis moins enthousiaste que
nicolas barreuse parce que dans ce qui a
été voté c'est pas simplement un
passeport pour voyager ça
on pourrait être d'accord a
effectivement ça existe déjà quand on va
en afrique par exemple faire vacciner
par pour la fièvre jaune
il ya d'autres vaccins qu'ils soient
obligatoires dans d'autres pays
mais là ça va être quelque chose de
beaucoup plus contraignant où on va
avoir cette espèce de passeport pour
aller aussi des mains pour aller au
théâtre au restaurant je passe pour qu'à
la fin ça aboutisse parce que ça reste
c'est risque encore d'être un monstre
technocratique mais en tout cas ça a été
voté sans qui est des basses qui est
quand même à inquiétant sans qu'il ait
de débat et alors même que la population
il semble hostile donc d'un point de vue
démocratique
voilà ça va pas encore réconciliés les
peuples avec l'europe et avec la
politique en général
et voilà et moi je pense que c'est allé
trop loin que de vouloir imposer un
passeport partout d'ailleurs je suis
permis à plusieurs jeunes personne ne
dit qu'on va l'imposer par tous il
s'agit pas de bassy banon lestir g20 le
respect envers ses fins étonnant qu'ils
aient dans les mondiaux
on va devoir présenter un passeport pour
aller acheter une baguette de pain
personne ne discute très aimablement de
ce genre de choses enfin la bannière par
tous les hôtels les noms je pense que le
si on voulait prendre la chose de
manière intelligente c'est pas
l'histoire de dire le cinéma ou le
théâtre ou de toute manière il faudra
continuer à voir des gestes barrières
c'est d'avoir des endroits où on
retrouve un certain nombre de personnes
grosso modo est ce que je sais pas si
c'est 506 et milou si ces 1500 ou 2000
mais par exemple si on veut rouvrir des
stades des salons des foires c'est pour
ce genre de choses que ça peut être
utile si on a un cinéma où par ailleurs
ou un théâtre où il ya une place sur
deux on va pas c'est pas la peine de
demander un c'est pas la peine de
demander un passeport et pour alexandre
qui aime bien l'histoire de france et
notre pays je lui rappellerai quand même
de manière que ce sont deux inventions
françaises
le passeport c'est louis xiv et ensuite
s'est systématisée par la révolution et
le vaccin c'est louis pasteur
donc c'est quand même très paradoxal
pour quelqu'un qui unit côté les vaccins
on a eu la discussion sur l'immigration
tout à l'heure
vous voyez que mais c'est pas un peu
s'appliquer aussi laxiste pour certaines
choses qui laissent voilà le lait les
gens entrer sans passeport et sans
papiers vouloir imposer aux citoyens des
papiers un peu partout ça me paraît ça
me paraît excessive d'autant plus que si
tout le monde est vaccinée ou cas où
plus de 60% de la population est
vaccinée est ce que ce sera bien utile
j'en suis pas certain ça peut même être
contre-productive vous dites ça va
permettre de réouvrir tel ou tel secteur
ben ça peut être aussi une
complexification qui va décourager
certaines personnes de retourner au
cinéma opéra ou des étrangers de venir
en france de donner un point je vous
demande d'être rapide passe rien on a
dépassé le temps imparti
non mais c'est pas grave mais juste
de deux questions par rapport à ça
effectivement est ce que de toute façon
et c'est quand même assez curieux que
déjà on interdise ou on conditionne
certains accès à ce qu'on appelle deux
esseulés c'est donc le schéma vaccinal
complet alors même que ça on ne pourra
pas être vaccinées d'ici la fin de l'été
et la deuxième chose la deuxième chose
c'est une question qui peut poser et je
trouve mais qui est la question c'est
qu'on mise tout sur les vaccins ont misé
sur les tests mais à aucun moment en
tout cas on ne rentrait peut on au mit
sur les sur les traitements et en
particulier sur la recherche sur les
traitements avec un ministre la santé
qui a quand même quasiment même interdit
certes un certain alors d'abord la
remarque évidemment une remarque de bon
sens il est hors de question de
conditionner et d'avoir ainsi si on n'a
pas de vaccin on ne sait pas comment ça
on n'a pas de passeport vaccinale ça ce
qui commence à 100 le choix il n'est pas
entre eux la liberté est à ce point
vaccinale je rappelle que le choix il
est entre retour à la case confinement
ou passeport vaccinale l'autre chose
c'est que bien sûr à pays comme la
france on peut espérer quand même qu'on
va finir par avoir un fort taux de
vaccination mais je rappelle que l'idée
c'est aussi de pouvoir voyager je vous
rappeler une chose c'est que le
transport aérien en chine
90 % de sa capacité aux états unis 50%
en europe 10 % donc si on reste comme ça
il faut être clair on va tous passer à
côté de la reprise est là encore quand
on passe à côté de la réalité c'est pas
seulement un problème économique c'est
un problème humain extrêmement important
derrière
donc voyez c'est ici c'est pour ça que
j'ai toujours assumé sur les traitements
il n'est pas vrai que qui est qui et pas
deux il est pas vrai qu'il est pas de
recherche
il ya des molécules qui sont en train
notamment le
les une molécule qui est utilisé contre
la sclérose en plaques et qui
aujourd'hui est testée mais c'est vrai
que pour l'instant j'ai dit là encore il
faut faire preuve de bon sens pour
l'instant on n'a pas de traitements
oraux il ya de la recherche mais on n'a
pas de traitement
on a des vaccins on a des tests donc il
faut pour le garder à sur le fait qu'ils
aient pas traitement vizela annonce il
ya débat vous avez encore un débat même
si ses comptes et suez sur les
professeurs rabais notamment non et ça
c'est très franchement le ms et tous les
gens sérieux donc le professeur out je
suis désolé mais si et pas seulement jeu
n'a pas être simplement si vous voulez
un regard des résultats des
vaticinations du professeur raoul tu
vous regardez ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis ce qui s'est passé au brésil
il sera démontré coûteux non mais il n'a
pas eu le traitement du professeur raoul
à végétaliser pas là il a préconisé un
moment donné où regarder ce qui se passe
au brésil avec effectivement ce qu'avait
préconisé rares bulles sun araw donc
franchement non aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de traitement mais on peut pas aimer il
ya des recherches néanmoins et donc il
faut la priorité c'est de sortir de
cette terrible épidémie plus vite
possible
donc pour l'instant il se trouve que les
outils à notre disposition c'est les
tests et les vaccins donc évidemment le
jour où il ya un traitement
il faudra l'intervention n'est d'accord
là dessus d'autant plus qu'il ya une
course contre la montre contre les
variants qui se joue dans les patients
que le vaccin va être efficace sans
vouloir être pessimiste à être cassante
c'est quand même question qui se pose
donc il faut toujours prévoir l'avenir
ensuite je suivais ça pose la question
de l'aide à des traitements parce que
s'il n'y a pas de le si les vaccins sont
pas efficaces sur a reposé la question
et je me suis d'accord pour le passeport
vacances de mon voyage et là on était
d'accord sur ce point je tiens à le
préciser est pas la même chose que le
passeport
voilà en permanence et encore une fois
effectivement ce qui paraît paradoxal et
un peu et riton je pense pour une partie
de la population c'est que l'europe
l'union europe les pays d'europe ont
pris quatre mois à six mois de retard
sur les autres pays occidentaux
par contre ils ont l'air d'être en
avance pour ce qui est du passeport
va-t-il à le mettre en place maintenant
ce serait créer situations d'inégalité
intenable il faut attendre qu'un maximum
de personnes soit merci je donne la
parole à nos internautes kriss kross qui
se dit que pour une fois il dira bravo à
roselyne bachelot marie kick les faux
passeports ne vont-ils pas circuler en
masse le flight 94 estime que impasse
sanitaire est utile
tout comme christian léon tout cas qui
posent la question prépa préférez-vous
le coc vide ou bien la vaccination c'est
le débat en tous les cas la question
qu'on vous posez sur twitter était la
suivante peut-on les pensez vous qu'on
peut échapper aux passeports sanitaires
et vous répondez non à 60% merci
beaucoup
on est en retard vous restez sur le site
du figaro on est à rambouillet avec
charlotte baryons de nos bruit et
thibault il aurait merci de nous avoir
suivis et vous pouvez justement
commenter cette mobilisation qu'il ya
actuellement dans la sous préfecture des
yvelines est également devant de
nombreux commissariats français et
également après ça vous pouvez vous
précipiter sur internet ou dans les
librairies encore ouvertes sans pass
sanitaires pour l'instant pour acheter
des livres de nicolas baverez et
d'alexandre ii équivaut à très vite sur
figure live le court qu'avant
[Musique]